so you may have heard this before maybe
another video this concept of
restricting calories and living longer
it's been a lot of research in this on
animals insects bacteria and yeast and
mice that if you actually cut their
calories they live longer but that
conflicts with all the people that have
done low calorie diets in the past it's
been proven that the more you diet and
you lower your calories you end up
gaining the weight back becoming bigger
and really struggling to stay on any
diet and not only that it destroys your
metabolism over time so how could the
restriction of calories end up making
you healthier and live longer that's
what I want to talk about so a couple
things most of the studies out there
we're done in animals not humans there
have been some studies done on humans
using the fasting mimicking diet where
you're doing meals that are 500 calories
a day there's also a program out there
called 5 and 2 okay where you can pretty
much eat what you want 5 days out of the
week but 2 of the days you're consuming
500 calories per day so you're
restricting your calories so there are a
couple problems with this and there's
some problems with this as well when you
do the fasting mimicking diet you're not
doing this
for any period of time you're doing it
for a short period of time and then
you're off of it you're going back to it
like a diet which I don't agree with
because what happens when you're not
fasting you can pretty much eat whatever
you want and that is something that's
not very workable the other big problem
when you lower calories is what are
those calories made up of if you're
doing low calories but higher carbs
you're going to keep your blood Sugar's
up and down up and down up and down so
you're going to be very hungry you can
actually be very uncomfortable you're
gonna be very weak you're gonna be very
irritable ok I've done these diets
before the only thing in my mind is that
big pizza I'm going to consume as soon
as I get off the diet and then you have
people that do low calorie and they're
doing with low fat that is going to
stimulate a lot of hunger again very
uncomfortable not sustainable and this
is a real big problem
people go on diets blood sugar issues
hungry all the time
you're gonna binge you're gonna go off
the program you're gonna then eat the
wrong foods and you're gonna do this
over and over again and every time you
do this you destroy your metabolism a
little bit more a little bit more so
let's talk about the real benefit when
you restrict calories the benefit is
epigenetics okay
epigenetics means above genetics so you
have certain amount of genes and then
you have the things that trigger these
genes
it's called expression of a certain gene
and the genes that affect longevity and
weight loss have to do with really
lowering your glucose and your insulin
these are the two powerful triggers for
the benefits of the calorie restriction
not the fact that you're restricting
calories but that you're restricting
glucose in insulin this is where the
benefits come from right here the other
big problem I see when people do low
calories is they lower the nutrients and
they create nutritional deficiencies
especially if they do it long term they
end up with all sorts of problems but if
you're new to my channel this is what I
recommend I do not recommend trying to
restrict your calories
I recommend you're stretching your
glucose and that that will indirectly
lower your insulin because so a low carb
diet very very important but not at low
fat diet so you want to increase your
fat moderate protein lower your carbs
what will happen is your body's going to
now shift it's going to shift its
metabolism over to fat burning your
hunger is gonna go away it's going to be
very easy to do you're not gonna have
the blood sugar issues why because your
carbs are low it's really about keeping
your carbs low and keeping you in
fat-burning it's gonna be very
comfortable and even pleasurable when
you're able to tap in your fat because
your hunger goes away and this makes it
sustainable so instead of going low
calorie or doing a 500 calorie meal I
recommend you do intra minute fasting
okay so you're gonna try to go without
any food as long as you can okay until
you're hungry and then you're gonna eat
why because that's gonna help lower
insulin okay and when you're lower
insulin all sorts of things happen
on the epigenetic level and the genetic
level as well you definitely live longer
you can have a lot of health benefits
and when you go from three meals a day
down to two meals a day down to one meal
a day you're naturally going to lower
your calories because there's no way
you're gonna be able to consume what you
would consume in three meals in one meal
but it's not the fact that you're
lowering calories that makes the
difference it's this right here don't
focus on calorie restriction focus on
healthy keto which is low carb higher
fat focus on nutrient-dense foods so you
have no malnutrition as well as
infrequent eating so this way it's
sustainable you can do it long-term
it'll be comfortable you won't be hungry
and you feel good thanks for watching if
you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos